hey everybody
uh really really sorry about that i
started the stream and we started
playing a song
and then my entire computer uh glitched
out and did one of those
forced windows 10 uh-oh there's a
problem and we're trying to fix it
blue screen fiascos and then an entire
restart everything is very sluggish
right now
and i think these are the windows gods
punishing me because
i had done a windows update the one that
yesterday popped up and said do you want
to restart now and i said hell no we're
in the middle of a stream
and um oh i love that people are
emailing me the live stream is down
i didn't know i i thought i was
streaming the last half hour i've been
talking to nobody
um no in all seriousness um
i think it was the windows gods
punishing me because i i never did that
restart
and i would the restart was going to be
forced on me one way or another so we
are back and we're standing by for white
house
press secretary jen saki i have
so many things to go over you guys uh to
go
over with you
yeah to go over with you yes that makes
sense
uh but yeah i may be getting a new
streaming computer soon anyway i think
we're gonna have to get
a little more power even though the
problems really they're windows problems
like i
i don't know it's just it's just windows
i don't know what else to tell you
okay where to even start uh first of all
just real quick on kovid i think
that what i said last week probably is
is right
in terms of what seemed to be an
increase a brief increase in cases
it's that there were a ton of cases
where tests were delayed because of the
weather i have a friend whose dad tested
positive yesterday the test was 11 days
ago
the test results were delayed a full
week because
of the weather issues so i think that a
lot of these cases here
really should have been up here and
we're probably just in the middle of a
continued
slower decline that what it looked like
for a few days
and then um in terms of deaths we also
saw a little
spike but then a decline again i think
things are going to continue down now
also very good news
we just had a record day yesterday for
vaccine doses
you can't this day looks like the record
but this is because nothing was reported
for three days prior this was like
catching up on all four days
this is the record yesterday 2.4 million
doses
i believe 2.5 2.6 million doses are soon
on the way per day
these are really good numbers and we got
the jnj vaccine emergency use order
approved so i
i continue to be optimistic about uh
that
and more and more people are soon going
to be able to get those vaccines and
that is all
absolutely fantastic now i do
un sadly i have a bunch of
unbanned requests to adjudicate
yesterday was a big stream with the
trump speech
some of them are really ugly they're
sort of not safe for children
so i'm going to uh
have to adjudicate those momentarily
oh but i don't have my mallet hold on
excuse me i just have to see if i can
reach it
ah here it is okay so i have the mallet
i also have
two new characters to introduce to you
via voicemail and also the guy we know
as prickless guy
he has come back out of nowhere and he
has voicemails so i have all of that i
also have new
um songs to play based on
uh one of the other new call there's
just so much going on i don't even know
where to start
so let me just start with making sure
i've thanked everybody
who has subscribed since we started
thanks to the offenders
as well as dirt nap for subscribing
via twitch very much appreciate that
let's see if my little counter is
working
yes it is okay good and also thank you
to
conan york as well as christopher larkin
for signing up at joinpackman.com we did
so we were on track for february to be
the worst
month from the standpoint of members in
six months thanks to yesterday and a
bunch of people signing up
it ended up being only the fifth worst
month in six months so that's better
i guess it means makes it the worst
month in five yeah i don't know what's
what sounds better
the the next to last in six or the worst
than five
i don't know i'm gonna have to think
about that okay
super chats joe rader says i'm in i.t
support with peace and love always
reboot asap after
updates well i learned that the hard way
uh robert says this is highly
unacceptable david i'm blaming this on
you shamelessly exploiting the thai
cooking channel with your pump and dump
ways
okay i i was cracking up yesterday
during the uh
trump speech i saw people
sending in chat the message
pacmantoontune2028
mattie sancho says the cpac stage was
shaped like a nazi symbol
and david you have lots to share for
with us share is good stream live is
good no glitch share with us yes
that has to be a joke right that can't
be a real super chat
david you have lots to share for with us
share as good stream live is good no
glitch share with us yes
i refuse to believe that that's real
just can't be okay let's just get into
a bunch of different things um first of
all
i have new songs you might remember that
this gentleman called in
the other day we don't yet have um
oh yeah we're i guess we're calling him
the haiku hillbilly
if you remember this i'll tell you one
thing boy
trump is more man than you'll ever be
trump is more american than you'll ever
be
trump has got more money than you'll
ever have
you are bought and paid for
joe [ __ ] biden
okay so we got a bunch of songs
yesterday i'm not gonna play
all of them again but i did get one new
one
i think without being disrespectful to
anybody they're all good
this one i think fits the most cleanly
in with the style of the show
this one is by overlaid take a listen to
this
i'll tell you one thing boy if there is
a kind of uh wwe
face i'll tell
i think this is the winner so far i'll
tell you one thing
boy we need a remix i'll tell you one
thing
boy really really good
[Music]
that almost sounds like isn't that an
nsync or a backstreet boys
uh melody in the background it's a joke
it's like a three-year joke
we need a remix trump is more american
than you'll ever be what do you guys
think what do we need as a nickname for
that gentleman
trump is more man than you'll ever be
i think that
[Music]
we need a remix what do you guys think
[Music]
this is good if it's a joke it's like a
three-year joke
the way he delivers it is almost um it's
almost like a poetry in a sense
joe [ __ ]
there's something about that that i like
that is really good i think that that is
absolutely top notch and of course we
love everybody i have this whole
uh i have a whole library of all these
different songs so at any time like this
is the haiku hillbilly section down here
if let's say in in other words if we had
something related to like massive dumps
i could say oh yeah dj physic
has that song about dumps so we could
pull that one up you know i maintain a
library and then we can go right to it
was over and then they did dumps they
call them dumps
big massive dumps uh in michigan and
pennsylvania
so anyway we're definitely going to be
adding this one to our library and the
library is
becoming quite extensive i'm not going
to lie but that i think that that one's
really really good okay so we got that
out of the way
now i got another call from the manic
moderate this is a guy who is very wound
up but his the things he says are sort
of centrist
so here's a new voicemail from manic
moderate take a listen
yes bob from lakeland florida man
yeah the number one's a cb radio reject
yeah buddy i used to be on cb all the
time talking all them truck drivers
going up down the freeway
they all upgraded to the internet now so
them days gone gone you know
my daddy used to tell me you just
talking about about
ted cruz you know you know donald trump
said his name was
live ted and his shirt you my daddy used
to turn out that
it takes one to no one so if he called
him a liar that's because he's a liar
too
so anyway so that's the manic moderate
he's continuing to just
rant he uses the full three minutes
aloud in the voicemail so we got that
and then lastly i got a message from
the prickless guy this is the guy who
leaves the following
uh i think it's this guy highly
triggered individual yeah this it's the
guy from this song
um this guy should i play this this is
one of the most
vile callers we have take a listen to
this i have not pre-screened this so i
let me just warn you this may not be
suitable for children for children
now that your uh your hero is there are
you going to sit there in your little
kimono
and wear your little hat right
because it's going to be called no free
speech read chinese communists
anyway so we haven't heard from him for
months but i finally did he left a short
voicemail take a listen
hey prick boy prickles why don't you
flap your freaking arms around you look
like a
deranged chicken idiot
what a joke you are i turn you on to get
a good laugh
how stupid you are why don't you go back
to
venice layla i've never been to
venezuela i've
it i'm from argentina i have no interest
really at this point in going to
venezuela
you jackass communist
this is the communism show sign up at
joinpakman.com
private enterprise we are communists of
course so anyway
that's the return of a prickless guy
so there's that and i have one other but
i'm going to save it because it's sort
of a whole
a whole can of worms that i would be
opening so i don't want to i don't want
to get into that right now
okay thanks very much appreciate that
and then also want to say thanks to a
few people who just signed up via twitch
prime
file transfer protocol the internal net
and a few other folks in fact it's five
people five people who just grabbed
subscriptions via twitch
other super chats coming in derethen
says he's right trump is twice the man
david by mass
trump in a sense trump is twice the man
i am that's not inaccurate in a sense
today is my birthday says jennifer it
would make me so happy if david wished
me a happy birthday
jennifer happy birthday i hope it is
excellent and let's keep it going
and make it a fantastic 2021.
chakaseki says can we remix the
polytonal polyrhythmic free jazz version
of the national anthem we heard
yesterday
you know what would be a great remix
concept
um oh this is another one about that
jody says i played the anthem for my
husband today and he almost passed out
from laughing
um i think a great video remix
would be that weird national anthem from
cpac
combined with my commentary over it i
think that that would be perfect for the
show
i can't imagine a better a better one
for the show
okay let's do ban adjudications
i have four unban requests these all are
from the last 24 hours
let's go directly into the first one
this first user
is named jimbo slice one up
jimbo slice was banned yesterday during
the trump
stream uh let's see what he said
trump okay hold on where does it start
trump 2024 trump pompeo 2024
wow you guys got a real station up one
that shows the greatest president ever
known to man
trump is royalty everyone waiting for
trump everything he says is gold
biden was in office when we lost five
hundred thousandth person
sad that sounds more like trump
derangement syndrome 150k watching
youtube fox news cpac and that with
google stomping view count
2024 will be his third term being
elected and then he was banned for
spreading
election disinformation the unban
request
is not sure why i've been banned but
thanks for your insight
dave i prefer to make my decisions using
all sides
this is this is borderline because
they're not necessarily insulting anyone
but you can't
spend ten minutes repeating election
lies about trump one trump one trump one
so unfortunately that is going to go
permaban
and that has been decided next one
user worst durid eu
who showed up yesterday and sent
almost like just a diarrhea of the
keyboard
let's take a look at it these are the
comments that got them banned
did you guys realize trump will be the
first u.s president to win
three times trump 2024 trump 2024
anyone with a functioning brain cell
fake news keck w
it's actually true keck w did you guys
realize trump will be the only u.s
president ever to win three elections
true fouchy biden tbhkw
well he's not wrong though trump 2024
trump 2024 trump 2024
they were banned their unban
request was intolerant much i thought it
was time for healing and unity
omega lull that is a very easy
deny and that one is a no-go
we have ruled on that one
next user bet you will who showed up
yesterday and said
shh david can't hear great speech from
trump
where is my 1400 still blaming trump
rachel levine is not a woman people that
don't work never know the price of gas i
don't know the price of gas
first of all i do work i don't know the
price of gas because i've had an
electric vehicle i'm off gas
uh science what's delusional about
saying [ __ ] are cheating at girls
sports they were banned
i don't even need to see the unbanned
requests that's permaban
but the unbanned request was hahaha
the smell of soy is nauseating
that is a permaban
adjudicated and then lastly here is a
user
oh this one's from 10 minutes ago user
travez
mccostler uh first followed us
today said hi [ __ ] you pacman
they were banned and their appeal is
[ __ ] you pacman so that is a deny
and they have been permabanned
and i think that that does it for today
uh for in for out today i mean that is
not
that is not a good ratio um
four perma bands out of four unban
requests
bloodbath absolute bloodbath today
um okay thanks to cody reno trish the
dish hack
foue and a whole bunch of other people
for
the twitch prime subs
that is uh four actually putting us
at 13. also want to say
a really special thank you to ulrike
albinson
ulrike just signed up at
joinpacman.com the website
is ready and waiting folks ready and
waiting grab a membership at
joinpacman.com the first day of the
month is the best
day what's going on here i really need
this new clip to come in
i wasn't joking when i said i think that
the unban requests
the gaveling broke the clip for my
earpiece
i have a new one on the way uh no in all
seriousness
i i would love it if you grabbed a
membership at joinedpakman.com
better21 is the coupon code let's take a
listen
he served as the deputy
the audio is better here today and as
the director of u.s citizenship and
immigration services from
2009 to 2013 during his tenure at dhs he
led the development and implementation
of daca
negotiated cyber security and homeland
security agreements with foreign
governments
cyber led the department's response to
ebola and zika
helped build and administer the blue
campaign to combat human trafficking
and developed an emergency relief
program for orphaned youth following the
tragic
2010 earthquake in haiti he's been kind
enough to offer to take some of your
questions as always i'll be the bad cop
cop with that i will turn it over to you
thank you very much jen and uh uh good
morning everyone
uh whoa double that um in a few minutes
to provide you with an overview
very strong of what we have done and are
continuing to do and what we are
dedicated
uh to achieving uh we are dedicated to
achieving
and quite frankly are working around the
clock to replace the cruelty of the past
administration
uh with an orderly humane
uh and safe immigration process could
work a little faster
and it will take time but rest assured
we are going to get it done
let me explain to you why it is hard and
wide is going to
take time i think it is important to
understand what we have inherited
because it defines
the situation as it currently stands
entire systems are not rebuilt in a day
or in a few weeks to put it succinctly
the prior administration
dismantled our nation's immigration
system in its entirety
um when i started 27 days ago
i learned that we did not have the
facilities available or
equipped to administer the humanitarian
laws that our congress passed
years ago we did not have the personnel
policies procedures or training to
administer
those laws quite frankly the entire
system
was gutted in addition
they tore down the central american
miners program
that allowed children to access
laws of protection without having to
take the perilous journey
north they cut off funding to the
northern triangle countries of guatemala
el salvador and honduras no planning had
been done
to protect the front line personnel of
the u.s customs and border protection
uh and other front line perce personnel
that addressed the needs of individuals
coming to our border
contracts had been entered that were
unlawful
or against the interests of the united
states department of
justice and that's just the tip of it
and i must tell you that it pains me
profoundly
to say this today on march 1st
the 18th anniversary of the u s
department of homeland security
it takes time to rebuild an entire
system
and to process individuals at the border
in a safe and just way that is
especially true
when we're in the midst of the pandemic
and are obligated of course
to adhere to the restrictions and
procedures hopefully he will be asked
couldn't biden do more
on another executive order to
temporarily halt the deportations
of the individuals who arrive at our
border it takes time
to build out of the depths of cruelty
that the administration
before us established what we are
see seeing now at the border is the
immediate
result of the dismantlement of the
system
and the time that it takes to rebuild it
virtually from scratch we have though
already begun and
to design and in fact have begun to
implement
a new innovative way to address the
needs
of the population that was forced to
remain in mexico
during the prior administration that
rebuilding
that innovative solution is but one part
of a multi-part strategy
to execute on the president's vision for
example we've also begun
to rebuild a process for young people to
be able to access
avenues of protection without having to
take uh the perilous journey
we have begun to develop and rebuild
the program to reunify individuals with
their families here
in the united states as was once the
case
the president set forth his bold vision
in his executive orders at the outset of
his administration
and we are driven to implement them
successfully
let me if i can take a a couple minutes
to explain that innovative system to
which i referred with respect to
how we are addressing the individuals
who were forced into the remain
in mexico program under the prior
administration
working very closely with the mexican
government and international
organizations
in mexico we have developed a virtual
platform that enables
individuals with active cases in the
remaining
mexico program to actually register
for relief using their phones the
international organizations then work
with those
individuals to test them process their
cases
and transport them safely and according
to a
defined schedule to the port of entry
where we
are awaiting them and can process them
through the port of entry uh
successfully
we started with one port and 25
individuals
a day we are now at three ports and we
have
um enhanced our processes at one of
those three ports
to reach a hundred individuals a day in
processing
to address the acute need in the camp
at matamoros which we have all heard so
much
about this is all
by the way at a time when we are also
addressing the needs of our frontline
personnel uh
soon after i took office on february
2nd we launched operation val vaccinate
our workforce
where we have really surged resources
and capabilities
according to the paradigm that has been
established by the covet 19
task force it's great to hear all this
stuff and this guy's competent but
really
the main issue is biden did one order on
stopping deportations and a texas judge
said the base the legal basis of that
was no good and stopped it
why hasn't biden done another eo he
could have done it there's a bunch of
different legal justifications he could
have used we've been talking about it if
he was committed to stopping the
removals he could have done another
executive order
this opportunity at the same time
to reiterate a message that we have
communicated
repeatedly throughout which is a message
to those individuals
who are thinking of coming to our border
they need
they need to wait it takes time
to rebuild the system from scratch
if they come if families come if single
adults come to the border we are
obligated to in the service of public
health
including the health of the very people
who are thinking of coming
um to impose the travel restrictions
under the cdc's title 42
authorities and return them uh to mexico
and we have done that there's questions
about title for individuals to wait
and i will say that they will wait with
a goal in mind
and that is our ability to rebuild
as quickly as possible a system
so that they don't have to take the the
dangerous journey
and we can uh enable them to access
humanitarian relief
from their countries of origin
um the fact of the matter is that
families and single adults are indeed
being
returned under the covet 19 restrictions
let me then turn to the issue and the
challenge of unaccompanied children
because i know that much
has been reported about the handling of
unaccompanied children
and let me just explain the process if i
may
when an unaccompanied child reaches the
border
and comes in between the ports of entry
uh u.s customs and border protection
personnel specifically of the united
states border patrol
brings that child to a border patrol
station for
processing uh the border patrol
is only a pass-through we are obligated
to turn that child over to the
department of health and human services
within 72 hours we are a pass-through
and then health and human services or
hhs of course
that is commonly referred to um
addresses the needs of that child as
uh hhs is identifying and vetting
sponsors in whose trust the child can be
placed
while the child is in immigration
proceedings
and so we um have the child
for a maximum of 72 hours and of course
uh given the pandemic in its
restrictions uh given
the extreme weather conditions in texas
a critical part
that 72-hour time frame was certainly uh
under stress as we all know
and as we can all understand and then
children
are in hhs custody for an average of
about 31 or 32
days finally let me turn
to um i think the most powerful
and heartbreaking example of the cruelty
that preceded
this administration and that is the
intentional separation of children
from their parents i am
the chairman i have the privilege of
serving at the president's
designation as the chairman of the
family reunification task force
uh the first lady has driven us to
action through her personal commitment
to this moral
imperative and that moral imperative is
to reunite
the families and restore them to the
fullest capacity that we as a united
states government
can do and i should say that we are not
doing it alone
we are working closely with council uh
for uh the separated family members
we are doing it along with
uh the countries of el salvador
guatemala and honduras i spoke
with the foreign minister of each of
those countries this past friday
we are doing it with non-governmental
organizations
and we intend to and will shortly
harness
the capabilities resources uh and desire
of the private sector
this is an um not only in all
of government but all of society effort
to do
what is right we are
hoping to reunite the families either
here
or or in the country of origin we hope
to be in a position
to give them the election this is all
sort of vague enough where like
it could be okay or maybe not
lawful pathways for them to remain in
the united states
and to address the family needs so we
are acting
as restoratively as possible
i am very proud i'm not even claiming he
has the ability to say more right now
i'm just saying he's painting a
particular picture of things that might
happen
director of the family reunification
task force
she began late last week most recently
she served as a senior director
of the migrant rights and justice
program of the
women's refugee commission she has
dedicated
her entire career to human rights and
she is a
extraordinary talent that will
bring justice and results
to this effort along with the resources
of the department of homeland security
the department of justice
the department of health and human
services and every other member of the
federal government
that has resources to bring to bear
it is because of the men and women of
the department of homeland security
and across the federal enterprise that
we will dig
out of the cruelty of the past
administration
and we will rebuild our nation's asylum
system
and all of our humanitarian programs
of which we have been historically so
proud
as a leader uh in the world and with
that jen um
i'm pleased to take questions
thank you secretary you mentioned that
it will take some time to uh rebuild the
department how long i mean obviously
you're asking the american people to be
patient these migrants to be patient
um how long will it take to uh to to
rebuild these systems and processes and
staffing
that you say you inherited uh that were
not there when you were inherited the
agency and then also on the family
unification task force
how how big is this population of
separated families right now separating
children and how many have you already
been able to reunify and what's the
timeline for getting them all in unified
um so uh in in but a few weeks
we already have designed
an innovative program to bring people in
through the ports of entry
those that most acutely in need by
reason
of the fact that they have been
remaining in mexico
for so long and we have already begun to
implement it
we are progressing every single day i
don't have a particular timeline
but all i can do is communicate both to
the american public
and to the individual seeking protection
that we are working around the clock
seven days a week
to make that time frame as short as
possible but they need to wait
but they need to wait with a particular
goal in mind we are not saying
don't come we are saying don't come now
because we will be able to deliver a
safe and orderly process to them as
quickly as possible
um there have been uh i understand
approximately 105 families
reunited in in the recent past
that is through the extraordinary
efforts of council and others in the
community
we are joining with council with members
of the community
uh to work on this and michelle will be
full-time
dedicating resources full-time across
the
government uh and the department of
homeland security specifically
uh to this effort the urgency of it
cannot be overstated
a question about how unaccompanied
migrant children are handled the process
that you articulated
is the same as it was under former
president trump it's the same as it was
under former president biden
right the difference as i understand it
with the trump administration was that
they held children
for a longer period of time how can that
process be sped up there are immigration
advocates who say most kids who come
here unaccompanied
have the name or a phone number of a
relative here in the u.s and that they
should be matched with them promptly
so let me let me if i may uh correct um
um one of the premises of your of your
question because you said
that we're handling them in the same way
uh that the trump administration did and
that is
that is absolutely um uh inaccurate
process that you articulated
well actually the trump administration
expelled children
uh to mexico uh and we are not expelling
young children we are not
apprehending a nine-year-old child who's
come alone
who's traversed mexico whose parents
whose loving parents had sent that child
alone we're not expelling that
nine-year-old child
to mexico when that child's origin
country of origin was guatemala honduras
or el salvador
we are actually bringing that child into
a border patrol station
as a stepping point to get that child
in the hands of hhs that has the
capacity and the
and the unique talents to care for the
child
health care workers mental health
counseling and the like
and moving that child to a sponsor as
quickly as possible
so we have taken a look at the process
that is in place
and we are re-engineering it to see for
example
whether we could have hhs personnel
collate
co-located in a border patrol station
start to identify the needs of the child
to see if that child does indeed have a
relative in the united
states identify the sponsor more quickly
and unite that child with the sponsor
more quickly
more quickly so a re-engineering we are
taking a look at
where efficiencies uh can be achieved
in the best interest of the child it is
the best interest of the child that
uh really define our actions
if i made just quickly looking at the
principles that you laid out
the work of the family reunification
task force i didn't see in their
accountability making sure that it never
happens again but also holding the trump
administration responsible for that
policy
holding them accountable the justice
department inspector general put out
basically a roadmap
that says that jeff sessions and doj
leadership at the time was responsible
for that
enforcing that zero tolerance policy so
so it's a
very important first of all those
principles
are our guide we are going to be
discussing
what can we do under the law because
remember we
must address the needs i'm kind of torn
between
he's he genuinely seems to want be
wanting to improve things and is limited
in what he can say because it's only
been a month
to a lot of bureaucratic pseudo-speak
that i'm i i
tend not to trust humane as the law
provides
to be as restorative as the law
enables us to be to bring justice to
these families
one of the tasks of the reunification
task force
will be of course in addition to
reuniting
those families which of course is the
most acute
urgency to also take a look at the
system
and ensure to your very important
question to ensure
that it does not happen again as the
president has so powerfully
said this is not who we are
mr secretary in south texas uh
several city officials are requesting
coveted tests from the state of texas
for migrants what plan is dhs putting in
place
to do covet testing for migrants so
if i can level set um on that
the the extraordinary weather that that
texas
uh suffered and to which the president
responded
with such urgency uh created a um
an unexpected stress uh on our system
as a matter of process uh individuals
of family units are brought into ice
custody they are tested ice has the
capability to test them
to isolate and quarantine them as the
results so dictate
and then to address their needs as the
immigration process
uh uh provides
so is it happening right now yes it is
okay if i can also ask you said please
don't
come you sent the message now is not the
time what specifically
and how is this administration conveying
that message to these desperate families
and you know people who respectfully
probably will not heed your warning to
please don't come now what are you doing
to convey the message
to them so multi-part
answer if i may number one of course
with respect to our resources we are
flooding
uh the space with that critical message
uh i cannot overstate its criticality
for the well-being of those very
individuals who are thinking of coming
uh not to mention the well-being uh and
stability of the border as we seek to
rebuild it
uh from its dismantled state right we
are not
communicating alone we are communicating
in partnership
with non-governmental organizations
community-based organizations
that do have the ear of these very
communities
and we are doing it in tandem with the
governments of mexico el salvador
guatemala
and honduras on the one hand we're all
right to be skeptical of the answers on
the other hand the fact that
actual policy is being discussed in such
depth in back and forth with media
is a very welcome change from the last
four years
aspects of the population and it is a
message that we
need to continue to communicate it is
our obligation
uh as a nation to do so mr secretary
thank you mr secretary
um do you believe that right now there
is a crisis at the border
i think that the uh the answer is no
i think there is a challenge at the
border that we are managing
and we have our resources dedicated to
to managing it
and so a lot of the things that you are
talking about you admit
take some time to implement but right
now you've got about 200
migrant children crossing the border
every single day
[Music]
cbp projected a peak of 13 000
unaccompanied children
in the month of may according to a
report in axios
what is being done between now and then
when you are able
to implement all the things that you're
talking about that you say will take
time
[Music]
let me let me answer that question with
tremendous pride
the men and women of the department of
homeland security
are working around the clock seven days
a week
to ensure that we do not have a crisis
at the border that we manage
the challenge as acute as the challenge
is
and they are not doing it alone this is
a challenge that the border communities
the non-governmental organizations uh
the people who
care for individuals seeking
humanitarian relief
all understand it is an imperative
everyone understands
what occurred before us what we need to
do now
and we are getting it done respectfully
one of your predecessors jay johnson he
said that a thousand
illegal border crossings a day
constitutes a crisis that it overwhelms
the system we're at between
three and four thousand now according to
cbp officials so
how is this not a crisis um i have
explained that quite clearly
we are challenged at the border the men
and women of the department of homeland
security
are meeting that challenge it is a
stressful challenge
and we are that is why quite frankly we
are working
as hard as we are not only in addressing
the urgency of the challenge
uh but also in building the capacity to
manage it
and to meet our humanitarian aspirations
and execution of the president's vision
uh thank you mr secretary does the
administration support using budget
reconciliation to legalize millions of
undocumented immigrants this year as
senator warren and 100 other democratic
lawmakers have called for
the president on day one sent a bill uh
to congress the president recently
spoke of that bill that bill
addresses what there is unanimity about
which is we are operating under a broken
immigration system
and we need to fix it typically would
you consider using the budget
reconciliation
it is not for me to decide the
legislative strategy
that the administration employs going to
have to cut it soon
to passing immigration legislation uh
and the administration um is pursuing a
path that everyone
understands is directly needed
you said that the previous
administration had entered into some
contracts that were unlawful
could you give us some examples of that
what do you mean let me let me give you
an example that already has been uh in
the public domain
quite frankly um and that is
uh the uh agreement on january 19th
one day before the new administration
was to commence
an agreement uh with the union
of immigration and customs enforcement
that the union must approve
any policy changes in the immigration
arena i have no i've been in government
uh for um almost 20 years
now i've never seen a contract like that
and i certainly haven't seen a contract
like that
on the last day of an administration
thank you mr secretary i'm with abc news
and we've reached out to hhs
and border patrol after the suggestion
from jen last week to try and gain
access to the tent facilities in texas
i'm sorry i didn't i didn't quite hear
but let me if i can
say one thing um back to that question
if i may
because there can be um honest
disagreements about policy
but there has to be an overriding um
credo and that is loyalty to our
institutions
and what they stand for and the
fundamental rule of law
and i find an agreement like that um
in dereliction of that duty yes i'll
project this time sorry
sorry i'm with abc we reached out to hhs
and the border patrol about gaining
access to the tent facilities in texas
we were told we can't because of covet
restrictions if there was a safe way to
do this to get reporters down there
to show the american people the
conditions there where these
unaccompanied children are being held
would you allow that i'm happy to
take a look at that i owe it to my
people to understand the situation and
the reasons
not going to commit to that denied i
will share with you
uh something um another um
uh principle to which don't worry he'll
tell you how things are down there my
tenure and that's openness and
transparency uh
and uh that includes the fourth estate i
actually grew up as a journalism student
but apparently
i wasn't a good enough writer to make it
the whole way um
let me let me share with you um
the easy answer would be to say i have
no problem but we have to talk about if
it's coveted safe and then in two days
you say sorry it's not coveted safe
service of openness and transparency
don't shrink from criticism
just work very hard not to deserve it
thank you very much
all right oh well i'm happy to take that
one i'm sorry
what is the status of the review of the
trump era visa bans for h-1b
visas and has the white house decided to
lift those bans before they expire at
the end of the month
you know i don't really um i hate to end
the questioning on an uh on a question
the the answer to which i am not
certain but but look uh
this goes to what preceded us
we have so much work to do to repair
and to restore and to rebuild
that we have a prioritization matrix
and of course the acute needs of
individuals
fleeing persecution is a high priority
which brings me
uh to this uh meeting this morning thank
you everyone
secretary we'd love to have you back
again there's clearly lots of questions
thank you so much
thank you thanks to danielle jim and
alicia for signing up at joinpakman.com
very much appreciate it we'll hear from
jensaki
just have a few more things only one
more thing at the top
um obviously the president's focus this
week in the coming weeks until it's
passed is on the american rescue plan
and i wanted to take the opportunity to
reiterate that in two weeks
on march 14th around 11 million
americans will start losing their
unemployment benefits if congress
doesn't act on the president's rescue
plan
there are 11 million americans who are
unemployed through no fault of their own
but who will struggle to put food on the
table struggle to make ends meet and
struggle to live with the dignity they
deserve
i'd also note that nearly 1 million
households on unemployment insurance
report that their children aren't eating
enough
more than 1.5 million more are behind on
their rent
or mortgage for almost a full year now
new unemployment claims have exceeded
the pre-pandemic all-time high
and the economic data shows a
case-shaped recovery with millions of
workers at risk of being
left behind that's why it's absolutely
critical congress act and
we certainly hope they do that as
quickly as possible
one last note today as many of you know
all of you know
the president will meet with president
andres manuel lopez
obrador the president of mexico building
on their uh
their january 22nd conversation the
meeting will reaffirm the enduring
partnership between both countries
based on mutual respect and the
extraordinary bond of family and
friendship
the president will be joined for the
meeting by secretary of state tony
blinken
secretary of homeland security alejandro
mayorkas spending a lot of time here
today clearly
and other white house officials to
discuss a new phase of the u.s mexico
bilateral
relationship with their counterparts the
discussion we expect will focus on
migration
recovery from covid 19 climate change
and security with that zeke kick it off
thank you again
uh what's the white house response to
iran's uh
let's see if we can see the reporters
here white house officials
always better when we can the u.s mexico
bilateral relationship
with their counterparts the discussion
we expect will focus on migration
recovery from covid
it's a little behind but i prefer to see
the reporters and security
with that zeke kick it off thank you
again uh what's the white house's
response to iran's uh
uh refusal to sit down from the uh for
uh negotiations uh
nuclear program and uh is there a sense
of urgency in the part of the white
house to go
on onto the table given the development
progression of this program
well um first let me say we're
disappointed
in iran's response we remain ready to
re-engage in meaningful diplomacy to
achieve a mutual return to compliance
with jcpoa commitments and we will be
consulting at every level with our p5
plus one partners
on the best way forward we do view this
though as a part of a diplomatic process
to determine the way forward and that's
what we'll be engaging through the prism
of
another foreign policy uh the president
has not taken any direct
action against the saudi crown prince in
response to his involvement
uh in in the murder journalist jeremiah
why not and what message is the
president saying to autocrats around the
world that they could
kill journalists or their own citizens
with impunity and not suffer
personal sanctions well let me first say
that um
you know this was a horrific crime uh
the president has been consistent
in reiterating that in his belief of
that got a delivery at the door guys
stand by on friday
through od and i did not contain new
information it was important to the
president that it was released
and it abided by our legal obligations
and it wasn't something
that was done by the prior
administration we also took a series of
strong steps to impose on individuals
directly involved in the operation
that led to the murder of jamal
khashoggi including adding
a senior saudi intelligence official
ahmed al-assiri to the list of those
facing
uh global magnitsky the global magnitude
designation i don't know why that's a
mouthful we also sanctioned under the
global mcnizi rule the entire rapid
intervention force
a unit of the saudi royal guard that has
engaged in counter-dissident operations
including the operation that resulted in
the killing of
jamal khashoggi this is a crucial step
because it structurally addresses an
unacceptable pattern of targeting
monitoring harassment and threats to
dissidents and journalists and we
believe
our team our national security team
believes that going after the network
responsible for these actions
is the best way to prevent a crime like
this from ever happening again
that is our objective going after the
network responsible but not the
man responsible for it why not uh
again you know i would say we took a
number of steps that our team determined
were the right steps to prevent this
from ever happening again
that is our objective we also from day
one even prior to the release of this
report
have recalibrated the relationship have
made clear that is going to be a shift
from how it was approached over the last
four years
that means counterpart to counterpart
conversations that means not holding
back and voicing concern
and pushing for action as it relates to
dissidents or journalists or others
being held
and it means making clear that we are
not going to support the ongoing
war in yemen we want to find a
conclusion of that war
so our objective is to recalibrate the
relationship
prevent this from ever happening again
and find ways as there are still
to work together with saudi leadership
while still making clear so my my pillow
delivery just came in
one more one um you spoke yesterday
about the sexual harassment allegations
against governor cuomo new york
has anyone from the white house reached
out directly to anyone to him or anyone
on his staff
and then is the president concerned that
this could serve as a distraction
from governor cuomo's handling of the
pandemic and should he
potentially step aside while this
investigation is underway
so that there are no strategic's not
going to say that
well as i stated yesterday
the president's view has been consistent
and clear
that every woman coming forward should
be tweeted treated with dignity
and respect that applies to charlotte
that applies to lindsay and any woman
coming forward and since yesterday of
course overnight
the attorney general has been made clear
that the attorney general
the new york attorney general will
oversee an independent investigation
with subpoena power just like with the
impeachment biden should just have
nothing to do biden shouldn't be telling
governors what to do
it should it just just don't get
involved see that through
go ahead just to follow up you reserve
the right to sanction the crown prince
in the future if deemed necessary right
of course we reserve the right to take
any action at a time and manner of our
choosing
i will note steve that historically uh
the united states through democratic and
republican presidents has not typically
sanctioned government leaders of
countries where we have
diplomatic relations and a separate
question we saw the statement last night
about alabama and amazon
is the president endorsing amazon
workers forming a union there
well the president uh broadly and i
think it was a video
just to so people know the context of
what you're referring to
the president believes that workers
should have the right to organize
that is a fundamental value he has and
one that he has
been consistent on for decades we don't
comment on specific cases where it is
before the nlrb or could be before the
nlrb so we aren't going to weigh in
specifically
on amazon but we uh broadly he believes
that
workers should have the right to
organize and hence he conveyed that in
the video
lastly on burma myanmar have you been
forceful enough in your sanctions on
myanmar because we keep seeing these
bloody crackdowns
and are you coordinating with allies to
look at more actions
uh we are absolutely we put out a
statement uh yesterday from national
security adviser jake sullivan
let me just reiterate a couple of the
pieces from that
that we remain alarmed by the burmese
security forces violent
violence against peaceful protesters the
killings represent an escalation of the
ongoing crackdown on pro-democracy
protesters since the february first
coup uh we are preparing the additional
actions to impose further costs on those
responsible for this latest outbreak of
violence
and the recent coup and we expect to
have more to share in that in the coming
days
uh go ahead and on back on saudi arabia
during the campaign obviously
former vice president joe biden was very
well aware of the history
of the us government in terms of who
they sanction and who they haven't but
yet he said
we're going to make them pay the price
and make them the pariah that they are
how does this come anywhere close to his
pledge
to americans in november of 2019. fair
question
well first the president has been clear
to his team and he's been clear publicly
that the relationship is not going to
look like what has looked like
in the past and even before the release
of the port report on friday
we had taken actions as an
administration to make that clear
through diplomatic conversations to our
partners and allies in the region
and through our actions and that
includes uh a
change in how we are communicating with
the saudis counterpart to counterpart
going back to
that appropriate line of communication
it includes not holding back and raising
concerns about human rights abuses
we did see last month that saudi arabia
did release
two dual national prisoners and women's
rights activists
it includes pulling back from our
support from the war in yemen
but it's important to also note that
there are areas where
we have a important relationship with
saudi arabia intelligence sharing
also helping defend against the threats
and the rocket attacks that they are
getting
um you know getting from bad actors uh
right at their doorstep and you know
global diplomacy requires um
holding uh countries accountable when
needed
but also acting in the national interest
of the united states and that's exactly
what the president's trying to do he
feel he's done a
good enough job explaining his position
his new position now as president of the
american people
and how is he reacting to the criticism
he's received over the weekend
and that christopher the new york times
uh accused him of choking
i know there were a variety of pretty
tough awards against him how has he
responded to that and does he need to
address it more
well i i don't think anyone runs for
president or is elected if they have a
thin skin
uh and certainly any action you take
on an issue like like global diplomacy
or an issue where there's a complicated
relationship
uh i think he fully expected there might
be some criticism but his
objective his role as president of the
united states and as commander of cheat
and chief of
the country is to act in the national
interests of the united states
and that's exactly what he's doing in
this relation in this uh in this case
uh that he's acting on the advice of his
national security team
uh and he believes this is the right
approach for our long-term interests if
i could ask a domestic one really
quickly
you said there were 14 days obviously
very critical 14 days to getting
the relief to the past what specifically
will he be doing
yes directly with democratic senators
good questions and republican centers
for actually reach out to
susan collins for example or other
republicans what are we doing here is
the question
the republicans were not on board the
house absolutely i think we're going to
be evaluating day by day what the needs
are so as you know he'll be meeting with
our via zoom a number of
democrats democratic senators this
afternoon we've reserved time in his
schedule to ensure that he can be
engaged roll up his sleeves and be
personally involved in
making phone calls having more zoom
meetings
potentially having people here to the
oval office to get this across the
finish line and i expect him to be
very involved personally on the
parliamentarian decision you said that
he respects
that decision but progressives don't
understand this in some respects they're
like why not
fight for this so why is the white house
not
more aggressively challenging that and
sending the vice president to try
and potentially overrule that with the
vote well
uh the the decision for a vice the vice
president to
vote to overrule or to take a step to
overrule is not a simple decision uh it
would also require 50 votes
uh as you know it's not a one-step
decision and the president and the vice
president
both respect i addressed this on today's
podcast and they are both
formally served in the senate and that's
not an action we intend to take
but i the president is committed to
raising the minimum wage
to working to determine the best vehicle
forward to doing that
that's why he put it in the package he
wants it to be raised to 15
an hour and he will be in touch with uh
leaders
from all wings of the party and
determining the best path forward for
that
go ahead jeff the follow up to jeff's
question which strikes me
the white house doesn't have 50 votes to
confirm near a tandem as omb
director and yet which is good white
house chief of staff say that the white
house is they're going to fight their
guts out
we don't want her confirmed to get her
confirmed so why
push for that and not push as hard one
could say
for raising the minimum wage you could
make the argument that the american
people stand to
benefit more from a higher wage than
they would from a chosen omb director
well i think that's mixing a few things
um kind of irresponsibly if i'm just
being totally honest
um wow i would say on the minimum wage
the president
raised the minimum wage in his package
because he felt strongly that it's long
overdue
that men and women working hard trying
to make ends meet shouldn't be living at
the poverty level that's why he put it
in his package
there is a process that it goes through
a parliamentary process
when it's a reconciliation bill as you
know but for people who haven't been
following all the nitty-gritty of this
because it's a budgetary bill uh that's
why it went through the process
and uh you know again i would i would
send you to talk to leaders in congress
to see if they have the 50 votes
necessary but regardless
the president the vice president have
made the decision they're not going to
move forward
uh with that step but also it's not a
simple process it requires two steps
as it relates to nira tandon she is
somebody who has decades of experience
uh she is qualified she is obviously
saki has to defend near a tandem but
tanden i called out on day one as the
worst of biden's picks
i said she may not even be able to get
confirmed i said this in 2020 it would
whenever it was that he announced it
and it's looking very bad for nero
tandon and that's a good thing
uh on voting rights the supreme court is
set to hear a major voting rights case
this week
you have by some estimates from 43
states republican-led states that are
set to
at least envision a change to election
laws and want to make it harder
but it put in place more restrictions on
voting the house is set to vote on the
john lewis voting rights act that is
running
headlong into a senate filibuster does
the president support
nixing the filibuster as a means of
passing voting rights
and if not how is he going to leverage
his political capital to make sure this
democratic priority becomes
law well first the president is
committed to
protecting the fundamental right to vote
and making it easier for all
eligible americans to vote his campaign
was about fighting
for democracy and we're going to
continue to fight for democracy in the
white house
and that's why we need to pass reforms
like h.r one
the for the people act and restore the
voting rights act and he's happy to see
the house take up hr one
this week we're not gonna get ahead of
the process the president's view on the
filibuster is well known
uh he has not changed that point of view
but certainly
uh any step to protect voting rights to
ensure that it's easier and not harder
for people to vote in the country we
feel is a positive step
we'll circle back okay ashley go ahead
that was that wasn't it with him saying
we'll circle back on that is just
mocking her
uh president biden supports an
independent review of this sexual
harassment allegations against him um
but one of those aides 25 years old she
didn't seem to like it
rather detailed specific language and
questions that she said the governor
asked her about her personal life that
made her feel uncomfortable
and the governor himself has not denied
asking these personal questions so my
question for you is
in general when it comes to sexual
misconduct where is the red line
for this president and the
administration is it only unwanted
physical overtures or is it a
unwelcome language between a boss and a
subordinate with a power difference kind
of a weird question
actually as i as i said yesterday that
story was incredibly uncomfortable to
read as a woman
and we certainly believe that every
woman coming forward
charlotte lindsay have
should be treated with respect and
dignity and be able to tell their story
and treat treated with respect uh there
is a process of reviewing as you noted
um an independent investigation they're
trying to get someone to
from the biden team to defend andrew
cuomo and it's like that
that's not they're not gonna do it they
didn't defend and they didn't defend
weiner
let the cards fall where they may
accepted the resignation of someone who
used simply language that was
inappropriate and abusive
is there a red line when it comes just
to language or is
president biden's red line does it have
to be something i'm not sure
a red line for whom i'm not sure what
you mean and what
like with what outcome for if the review
shows that governor cuomo what she's
saying is when will biden say cuomo
should resign that's the question she
really wants to ask
forcible kiss or an unwelcome physical
overture but just mere questions about
someone's personal life um or sex life
or romantic life or anything that makes
someone imagine asking kaylee what
trump's red line is on sexual harassment
relationship with someone in power is
that something where someone should
have to resign there it is there it is
that's what i mean by that
look the the the language um the
um uh you know the president has a bar
for what is expected in his
administration which you referenced
treating people's civility uh treating
people with respect
and that's what bar he holds in his
administration in terms of the path
forward
uh and the outcome of the investigation
it's cancel-baiting that's exactly what
it is
to conclude that and then on schools
first i want to make sure i understand
president biden's 100-day pledge to
reopen schools
is that getting 51 of k-8 schools
open five days a week am i correct on
that uh the majority of schools open
five days a week that is certainly our
objective and that it was one day a week
we hope our secretary of education is
confirmed soon who will be
overseeing that process moving forward
five days a week
is that every single kid who wants to be
in school that individual kid is going
five days a week or is that the building
open five days a week but kids perhaps
doing a hybrid model half the class on
mondays and wednesdays the other half
we'd like kids to be able to be in
school five days a week
thank you go ahead kristen thank you jen
um so when the president of mexico meets
with president
a little bit later today he is expected
to ask if president biden would consider
sharing part of the u.s coronavirus
vaccine supply
with his country is this something that
president biden is considering
no uh the president has made clear that
he is focused on ensuring that vaccines
are accessible to every american
that is our focus the next step is
economic recovery
and that is ensuring that our neighbors
mexican you could answer this by saying
once we have enough vaccines for
everybody who wants one in the u.s we
will of course
look to help our allies the
administration's focus is on
ensuring that every american is
vaccinated
uh and once we accomplish that objective
we're happy to discuss
oh uh further steps there it is okay
should have just gone right to the
president of mexico is expected to
propose
is an idea to bring an immigrant labor
program to the us that could bring
600 to 800 000 immigrants a year to work
legally in the united states uh is that
something
president biden would consider i i've
seen reports of that i believe that's a
step that would require
congress i'm sure we'll have a readout
after uh the
bilateral meeting this afternoon and
they both will be speaking after it as
well
okay one more question about the strike
in syria
uh the democratic senator mark warner he
said over the weekend that he really
wished that the biden administration had
given congress
more of a heads up he said i wish the
biden team would have given congress
greater knowledge
and greater warning so given the
criticism that you and
other administration officials had
leveled at the trump administration
uh when they strike syria back in 2017
why not go more out of the way to loop
in congress
well there were notifications made um to
the appropriate um
committee chairs and uh there there has
also been an offer of classified
briefings to anyone who would like a
classified briefing
and we concluded a range of
notifications on friday
um in terms of uh the strike in 2017 uh
that was a
strike of uh that would excuse me that
was a that was a
an attack uh on uh on syrian
militant military installations in
response to a chemical weapons attack
this was in response to a threat and
attacks the threat this is
very dicey logic because everybody's
using the 2001 authorization for
military force to justify what they're
doing biden did it trump did it
i talk about this on today's podcast i
think it's very dubious
and hypocritical he said
president joe biden sold out america's
children
to the teachers union how does the white
house respond to that
i think we're going to spend more of our
time focused on communicating about our
agenda for the american people
than responding to uh criticism from
uh the former president uh go ahead
thanks jen um to go back to uh saudi and
the crown prince and the quote that jeff
brought up from then
candidate joe biden in 2019 you
mentioned uh
holding countries accountable you
mentioned today acting in the national
interest but
he said in 2019 we're going to make them
pay the price
saudi leaders how is the administration
making the
crown prince pay a price and are you
saying that
the national interest and holding them
accountable can't square with
paying a price no i'm certainly not
saying that i was outlining a number of
the steps that were announced on friday
that were taken that specifically
addressed
uh sanctioned the deputy head of
intelligence that
specifically uh sanctioned under the
magnitsky act the entire rapid
intervention force which is a force that
is close to
the uh the crown prince and i was
referring to specifically
our uh goal of recalibrating the entire
relationship which is something that we
started to do from day one of the
administration we did not
wait for the release of the report but i
was also noting that
this is a country where we have
diplomatic relations we are going to
hold them accountable we are going to
take steps we are not going to hold back
on making clear where actions are
unacceptable where there needs to be a
change and reforms
put in place while also recognizing that
there are areas we need to continue to
work together on because they're in the
interest of the united states and our
own security
and you mentioned the historically not
sanctioning leaders of foreign
governments that we have diplomatic
relations with you just said it then you
said it yesterday
is it the policy though of the biden
administration to not
sanction a foreign leader if there are
diplomatic relations more than just
good question good question it's
considerations
considerations are done on a
case-by-case basis but i think that's an
important
uh precedent because obviously taking
that step
uh is something that there is not a
great deal of historic precedent for and
that was why i noted it
the intelligence community's conclusion
that the crown prince approved the
murder operation the murder of jamal
khashoggi
if that's not something that would
change the precedent what would
again we took a number of steps that
were
considered and determined by our
national security team
to have the intended impact of
preventing this from ever happening
again
and not just in saudi arabia but around
the world including the implementation
of the khashoggi rule
allowing the state department to
restrict or revoke visas to any
individual
believed to be targeting perceived
dissidents or journalists
including the sanctions that i've just
outlined against the saudi
rapid intervention force against the
deputy head of
general intelligence for his role in the
operation
we have also conveyed uh very clearly
uh and candidly through diplomatic
channels
that this absolutely can never happen
again that our relationship will be
different from what it has been in the
past
and that we are going to be uh of course
hold the option of holding
uh of holding um
you know saudi arabia to uh to their
commitment
uh to uh to to take put reforms in place
i don't think jen's loving some of the
questions today is my instinct
thank you i've got a couple questions
just like my front row colleagues
sure given the white house promised to
release
visitor logs why hasn't the
administration divulged who the
president
is being with virtually i mean we're in
the middle of a pandemic isn't that kind
of transparency
really important and also wouldn't be
really easy to do he's
meeting with members of the senate
virtually today there i've released it
for you what else would you like to know
what names
oh i think we did release the names if
we haven't we certainly have every
intention of doing that this afternoon
very good um we've been talking a lot
about congress and sort of the the log
jam that that has been
i'm wondering is the president looking
at the proposal that was released by
house appropriations chair
rosa uh delora when it comes to bringing
earmarks back
is that something that i know that he's
a legislator himself but is that
something that
he's interested in maybe that could
hurry along some of the agenda or
does he not have an opinion on earmarks
i i have not discussed that with our
legislative team obviously as you noted
he was in the senate for 36 years
we are our focus right now is on the
american rescue plan you're familiar
with all the components of that bill
because we talk about it
constantly from here but i don't have
any uh new position or a position on
that particular piece of legislation i
will check and see if there's anything
more we would like to convey
go ahead oh sorry go ahead go ahead
thank you go ahead
senator warren proposed a wealth tax on
households that are worth at least 50
million saying quote
this is money that should be invested in
child care and early education
infrastructure all of which are
priorities of president obama
but never supported that does this
president have any appetite
for wealth tax well the president
strongly believes that the ultra wealthy
incorporations
need to finally start paying it's kind
of a throwaway because it's like biden
didn't run on that
that's why he proposed making sure the
very
richest americans pay the same rate on
the income from their wealth that a
worker pays
as well as closing loopholes that allow
them to entirely escape
tax obviously our focus is on the
american rescue plan
addressing uh the inequities in the tax
code is something he talked about as
part of his build back better agenda
and is something he remains committed to
he has a lot of respect for senator
warren and is aligned on the goal of
ensuring
the ultra wealthy and big corporations
finally pay their fair share he's laid
out a lot of ideas and when we get to
that point in our agenda he'll look
forward to working with her and others
in congress
go ahead thank you jen very much so
yesterday former president trump
suggested he might run again in um
he'll be back in 2024. you say the white
house does not pay attention to
to president trump from president trump
but how do you think foreign leaders
are looking at these because this you
have to ask them
what is biden's opinion of how foreign
leaders look at what trump is doing i
don't know
if they can trust anyone's again so how
do you
also think president biden can convince
global
allies that they can trust the united
states and reclaim
u.s leadership well the president
president biden
uh just decisively beat uh donald trump
a few months ago that's why we're all
here
having so much fun together in here and
but his focus and i think one of the
ways that he convinces
foreign allies and partners that america
is back and we we want to seat at the
table
is by keeping his focus on his
commitments he made
on the campaign trail which is building
the economy back better
bringing it into the pandemic rebuilding
our relationships around the world
and not focusing time and energy and
effort on a political campaign
there's plenty of time for that i feel
like the what are the thoughts of like
if i was in there i would
i wouldn't get an answer but i'd frame
my question says uh joe biden promised
checks right away
on what date would we say that right
away has failed is it march 15 is it
april
1st you know today is march 1. is it
already a failure is march 1 right away
and see what they have to say i have one
more question about sure brazil so
sure the who said that it is a tragedy
happening in brazil right now
because of the pandemic what is the
white house evaluation of
the situation in brazil and how brazil
is responding to this crisis
well first let me note that on just
about a month ago
the united states through the us through
usaid announced it has delivered an
addition
1.5 million dollars for emergency
covid19 response
in brazil we did that of course because
we want to be a collaborative and
cooperative partner in addressing the
pandemic
our focus is on uh here
is on getting the american people
vaccinated that needs to be our focus
now
but of course we believe that the more
people in our global community who are
vaccinated the safer we all are
it's just what our current focus is uh
at this point in time
it's in conversation with the brazilian
government about
the situation there do you think also
there is a tragedy going on in brazil
right now happening in brazil certainly
the loss of life
the number of people who have been
impacted in brazil and many places i
don't know that bolsonaro is going to
listen to biden i mean
tragedy uh but in terms of specific
conversations i'd refer you to the
state department they would have more
specifics and more updated conversations
to read after you
go just one more question about uh south
america there was uh
some hope in south america the president
badin would be a
ally because he was he has experienced
leading uh
issues in the region during the obama
administration
but uh so far in more than a month uh
president biden has not spoken
with any leader in south america so i
wonder
what would be his priority in the region
and also who might be
his best partner in the region who would
be the first one who would call
we'll see i i promise you that uh the
president would love to spend even more
time calling
uh foreign leaders and there's just a
lot of course on his schedule i expect
he will do many more
foreign leader calls uh in the coming
weeks and certainly would
have discussions with many leaders in
south america but i don't have any
prediction for you about who or when go
ahead
during the cove briefing earlier today
jeff science acknowledged that
you know people were having a lot of
frustration getting vaccine appointments
and a lot of problems with the state
portals
is there any discussion at this point
given those problems with setting up
some sort of nationwide portal
for people to access i doubt it well
there was an announcement we made last
week about uh vaccine finder and it's
just available of course in about a half
a dozen states at this point in time
but what we're working to do is take a
number of steps to ensure people have
access to
more easily figure out when they can get
a vaccine when they're eligible in part
because as you know
everybody doesn't have access to the
internet everybody that's very different
than getting an appointment
you know a portal to tell you what who's
eligible in what state you can put
together in 24 hours
the scheduling federal platform sheet
the reporters talking about is a much
bigger lift
you know proactive outreach other ways
to reach people who are having trouble
figuring out
how to gain access to a vaccine and when
they'll be eligible
okay just one more question if you don't
mind senators widen and sanders dropped
their plan
today for taxing companies that did not
pay a higher minimum wage i'm wondering
what is the plan c at this point for
getting some sort of minimum wage
increase through congress over the next
several months
good question well it is an issue that
the president remains committed to he
wants the minimum wage to be raised
um that's why he put it in his package
and he
is going to be in conversations and we
will be at a number of levels
with members of congress with their
staffs about the best vehicle
moving forward but we don't have a clear
answer on what that looks like at this
point it just remains a commitment and
something he will
use his political capital to get done
good job in the white house has he been
standing up here
um the office has released the senators
who will be
meeting virtually with this afternoon
there are nine senators okay
um would you consider opening the top of
that up so we can hear from the
president directly
on this 14-day critical uh push
and if not why is that meeting not open
well
it's a video call i'm happy to check
with our team and see
um he opened the video called his
commitment to getting the american
rescue plan passed and the reasons why
uh nearly on a daily basis so i don't
think you've had a shortage of that
he'll also be speaking
after the bilateral meeting with mexico
but i'll check and see if there's more
that can be done
uh go ahead yeah um donald trump last
night
said everybody should get their kovic 19
shot
is that something you would welcome his
intervention and given that republicans
as a group seem rather more reluctant to
get there
we want everybody to get it period sure
um as many americans as possible
uh are vaccinated as quickly as possible
and we will have enough vaccines to
vaccinate uh ensure every american has a
vaccine by the end of july if not sooner
likely sooner so our at a certain point
we're going to reach
uh we will have more vaccines than there
are people who want to take them that
doesn't seem like
where we're going to be at this point
but we will reach that point in time
and we certainly welcome the
encouragement from anyone to take a
vaccine
and if i could um ann sacalis is still
wanted in the uk on charges of causing
death by dangerous driving
now the original rationale for her
leaving the country with diplomatic
immunity was that she was the spouse
of somebody who was working at raf
crouton which that story was a mess
agreement there
meant she had diplomatic community it
seems to have emerged
from her lawyer in court here that she
was actually employed
by the state department or the u.s
intelligence services
i wonder if you can clarify whether she
was working in the uk
for the united states government and
whether she does actually as far as
you're concerned have diplomatic
immunity
i would point you to the state
department they of course engage in any
questions about
uh diplomacy diplomatic immunity um
of course the status of somebody who
served during the prior administration i
don't have anything more for you
from it on it from here go ahead in the
back uh hi thanks um can i ask about the
g7
uh in june sure can you lay out some of
what the president
wants to focus on there and um also is
it expected to be
his first overseas trade we're not quite
there yet
in terms of laying out his exact agenda
obviously there are
uh global objectives getting the
pandemic under control
working together to get our economy up
and going again which is something that
the united states
is obviously grappling with but many
countries around the world are grappling
with
i'm certain those will be part of the
agenda but we're not quite at the point
of previewing a
summit that's happening in a few months
a lot can happen in the world between
now and then
in terms of whether or not uh he will
travel uh we haven't made a
determination on that
at this point either uh it it will be
related to
uh covid restrictions and um the advice
of our health and medical team and
expect as we get closer we'll have more
of an update there a possibility that
you won't
attend in person again we'll we'll
evaluate as we get closer there's
certainly a possibility um but uh we're
we are several months away
go ahead um i have a couple questions
about scrolling myself and then
something
sure um with three vaccines available
the administration has said it will
distribute
all three proportionally and then tell
states to distribute the effectively
my question is that the johnson johnson
vaccine vaccine is just the one dose why
not prior
prioritize that for communities that are
harder to reach and maybe harder to
convince to come back and get that
second dose
well the determination is made by the
fda
on kind of how these vaccines should be
distributed and where
i will say that the advice and guidance
we've been uh we've
we've received from our health and
medical team is that
uh every american should take whatever
vaccine is available
when it's their turn and in terms of
distribution of those vaccines generally
speaking
if we're distributing the johnson
johnson vaccine or we will distribute i
should say
just like we distribute pfizer and
modernise vaccine proportional to a
state's population and through
our federal channels so if a state makes
up five percent of the population it
will get five percent of the
pfizer allocation five percent of the
modern allocation
and five percent of the johnson and
johnson allocation
all three vaccines are highly effective
uh all three
and this is certainly a an incredible uh
a step forward and a new tool that we
have now in our uh in our um arsenal
quiver to address the crisis
uh but uh the guidance we are providing
based on the advice from our health and
medical team is that
any american should take uh whatever
vaccine that is available to them
not a great answer counteract any
messaging that the johnson johnson
vaccine is
inferior to the other two that have
greater efficacy
let's see what she says i think the
clear message we're sending is that
all of these vaccines are safe they are
effective
i mean it's increasingly looking like
part of the reduced efficacy on j and j
is because it was already being tested
on some of the variants which
if the moderna and pfizer had been
tested on the numbers would also have
been a little bit lower
that's increasingly the theory um you
know any
vaccine you have access to you should
take that vaccine
and we are not there's no we will be
certainly also tracking
if vaccines are only going to certain
communities and we'll be addressing
those issues as they come up
a couple of other colleagues who aren't
here now that the covenant bill has
passed the house has the president had
any more contact with speaker pelosi
about scheduling his joint address to
congress
that's such a popular question uh i
don't expect that
we don't have any update on it i don't
expect that uh the president will
uh be laying out the next stage of his
agenda until after we get the american
rescue plan passed and we're certainly
hopeful that
we do that in the coming weeks on his um
first press conference
not yet but we will definitely have one
we will schedule it and you will be the
first to know because you're pivotal
participants in that
last question here um when does
president biden plan to begin submitting
nominations for judicial vacancies
it's a great question it certainly is
something on his mind and a priority for
him
given his long history obviously as
former chairman of the judiciary
committee
i don't have an update for you on the
timing but uh it's it's something that
he has focused on personally
[Music]
in these conversations with foreign
leaders um phone calls and our meetings
uh is president biden discussing at all
the track of the white
white supremacy uh domestic violent
extremism
uh certainly it's uh it's anyways but
you know
around the world discussing here in the
u.s and around the world well there's an
ongoing review as you know and we're
allowing that policy process to see
itself
through he does receive regular updates
from his homeland security team and
others on
incidents happening around i don't
dislike that brazilian journalist but a
lot of our questions are
i don't i don't find her questions that
interesting or productive
to convey that it is a priority for him
on the national security
uh front in addressing that that's why
he asked his team to
conduct a full review and why we'll look
at that before we put new policies in
place
does he believe well white supremacy is
a threat to the national security and
maybe further
transmit transnational threat
he certainly wouldn't have asked the
national security team to conduct a full
review
of domestic violent extremism including
of course
activities of white supremacists if he
did not think it was a threat
thank you everyone all right
there is another briefing in the books
from white house press secretary
jen saki very very wide range of
questions
and i appreciate everybody joining me
today we are going to raid
oh let's raid sam cedar sam cedar
is actually streaming right now so let's
go over and raid
sam via twitch otherwise
i hope everybody comes back very soon
make sure you're subscribed on youtube
liked on facebook and followed on twitch
and we are going to have so many more
streams upcoming it's going to be
really streams like you've never been
able to do so before to quote the great
uh george w bush all right we'll see
everybody soon follow me for the raid
here on twitch
you